[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Have you ever wondered
how video monitoring
systems are architected?
Well, today you're
in luck as we explore
how Arcules, a video
monitoring IoT company,
created their
architecture in the cloud.
I've invited Ben, their cloud
and security architect, who
will share more with us today.
Hey, Ben.
Welcome to the show.
How are you?
And what do you do at Arcules?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi.
Thank you, Priyanka.
My name is Ben.
I am the cloud and
security architect,
although Arcules is
still a startup vibe.
We operate under more of
a collaborative product
team, which allows me
to wear multiple hats.
I not only get to work on
architecture and security,
but also get to work
on machine learning,
look after multiple
teams, and also get
to experience more hands-on
with our enterprise customers.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Wow, that is
all sorts of different things!
From ML to security,
that's a huge spectrum
that you work with.
So we know, at a
very high-level,
how video and IoT
monitoring works,
but I'm curious what
Arcules exactly does.
BEN: Arcules takes
all of the information
from a multitude of
devices at the edge.
And what we do is we
have a small appliance
at the edge that captures
all that information
and then processes
it and then pushes it
all the way through into the
cloud, specifically the Google
Cloud.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: All right.
That makes sense to me.
We have some devices.
They're sending
data to the cloud,
and then there's some processing
happening with that data.
How is it actually architected?
And, I guess, before
we even get to how is
it actually architected, what
is video security as a service?
And then we can dive
into the architecture.
BEN: Sure.
Video security as a service
is like a SaaS-based product
that's obviously storing video.
Typically, our
traditional competitors
are VMSes, which are video
management solutions.
What they do is they collect
all this video information,
make it easy for people to
find incidences or people
within video across
hundreds of cameras.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK, Ben.
So what are the challenges in
building a system like this?
And I'm actually really
curious about why you
chose Google Cloud for this.
BEN: We chose Google Cloud
primarily because of speed.
We evaluated multiple
cloud providers at the time
because we wanted more
of that on-premise feel.
Google won out.
The other key aspect
to this as well
was access your product
managers and engineers directly.
That really helped
us as a startup
to be able to get more
information faster and help
train our engineers
up quicker as well.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: All right.
So time to get into the
architecture and the details.
And you've given an indication
that obviously there's
customer sites where you
have the IoT devices that
are sending the data
into Google Cloud
and then there's processing
happening on there.
But I'm curious about
how the data makes it
from those IoT devices
into the cloud and then
what happens afterwards?
BEN: So each of
our customer sites
ultimately have
a small appliance
at the edge that
allows us to buffer
the information before it
makes its way to the cloud.
As we all know,
internet's super reliable.
So we are hardware-agnostic.
We can deploy on any Bare Metal.
We can also deploy
inside of VMware.
And then we have
Kubernetes at the edge.
That allows us to deploy
multiple containers
and different systems as
needed and, ultimately, shift
compute where it should be.
Then, also, we have our
last-mile connectivity.
That's really powerful
because that's primarily
the reason why we chose Google.
We're able to provide
almost near zero latency.
Ultimately, it's just
that last mile piece.
So we're able to
actually deliver
video subsecond to anyone,
anywhere in the world.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Awesome.
So we got into Google
Cloud at this point.
Before the data gets into
the services running on GKE,
you must have some
load balancing
that's happening, right?
BEN: Yeah.
So we actually have over 90
micro-services in GKE today.
So we really utilize GKE.
It's super awesome.
But before, obviously,
we hit the GK instance,
we do use our load balances.
We use both L7 load balancers.
We do utilize some of the
more interesting features
that you have inside of the
HTTP, HTTPS load balancing
and endpoint
connections, but we also
use a lot of L4, for
instance, with WebRTC.
And then, finally, we
have IoT Core as well.
With IoT Core, we actually use
that for some of our metadata.
The metadata flows
up through from some
of those services at the edge.
And that feeds
into pub/sub, which
then also feeds into BigQuery.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: We didn't
talk much about the databases
that you're using.
I assume you have pretty much
the spread of both relational
and non-relational
in this use case.
But can you talk more
about the databases?
BEN: Sure.
We utilize all
kinds of databases,
some hyper-specific,
some not so specific.
Probably one of our biggest
uses today, we actually
use Cloud SQL, again,
with that lighter weight,
not needing to have to
manage those instances.
We use both Postgres and a bit
of MySQL, primarily Postgres.
We also use, like you
mentioned, a couple
of other more exotic databases.
We actually use graph
databases, including Arango.
We actually have an interesting
NIST-based permission graph
model which makes
permissions way better
for horizontally scaling.
Traditional methods
don't work so well.
Singlestore we actually use that
for a high rate of ingestion.
We've tested that to more than
400,000 inserts per second.
The Postgres is mostly used
for our device configuration.
We have tens of thousands
of devices globally.
All of our configurations
are stored in our Cloud SQL
Postgres units.
|And then BigQuery we
actually use for slow storage.
So as we connect and have
all these different pieces
of information coming
in through metadata,
we slow store that inside of
BigQuery and obviously really
powerful to be able to run
jobs across large data sets.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Wow, that is a lot.
Like I imagine, it is a spread
of all sorts of databases.
I want to go back a little bit
and dive into the video files
themselves.
I think you mentioned,
briefly touched on the fact,
that these video
files are chunked,
and then you put them
into cloud storage.
So can you talk a little
bit about that process?
Because, yes, the
files are stored
in cloud storage,
but the way you
do them sounds really unique.
So I want to know
more about that.
BEN: So the video is
mostly stored today
inside of the custom container
format that we ultimately use.
Under the hood is
ultimtely H.264, which
is a very common video format.
Within video, you
have keyframes,
and those key frames
are chunked up.
Depending on the
camera, they may
be at one second, two
seconds, four seconds.
And that's how we ultimately
split that data up.
So we could be pushing millions
of files per month per device
depending on how that's created.
We actually recently
built a new way
of aggregating that
information, so
that we didn't have to spend so
much money on to PUT requests.
And we use that in
combination with pub/sub.
All these messages
fly through pub/sub
and allow us to get those
into the information,
into the databases to
allow quicker access.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
that makes a lot of sense.
Now, deployment,
what's your CICD like?
How do you deploy
these microservices?
I heard 19 services, so
I'm really curious how
the deployment works.
BEN: We use a multitude
of different services.
Deployment itself is
typically through Seneca,
but our build process is
actually through the Cloud
Build platform.
We also heavy users
of the container
services that you have as
well for container management
and deployment.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So how do you
actually monitor these systems?
Because there is a
lot happening here.
BEN: We use Cloud
Operations primarily
as it's native to
the Google platform.
That's a huge win for us.
We also use New Relic.
We also use Dynatrace
for some services.
And then we have our own
stack with [? Profoner ?]
and Prometheus as well,
depending on the services
that are being monitored.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: When
it comes to dealing
with a platform like
this, security obviously
is extremely important,
because you're
pretty much doing video and
dealing with sensitive data.
So specifically monitoring
any open ports also,
it could be a problem.
So how do you make sure your
architecture and components are
secure?
BEN: So that's really,
really interesting.
We use, again, multiple
products to do that.
We have our third-party
penetration test companies
that we have, we
contract with to make
sure we have that covered from
an external, true external
perspective.
Internally, we do
utilize the API scanners.
We also use the Cloud
Security Command Center
that you have as well
inside of the product that
does provide some pretty good
basic CIS stuff, which really
helps us understand which ports
are open, whether something
was configured.
We do have some other
special sauce as well,
which I unfortunately
cannot talk about.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Thanks, Ben.
I learned a lot with that
entire architecture diagram.
But what do future
technical enhancements
to this architecture look like?
And what is the next generation
of video analysis system?
I'm pretty sure
you're imagining it,
so I want to know
more about that.
BEN: From an
architectural standpoint
and from more of like kind
of operation standpoint,
I think the next things
for us are actually
implementing Istio, maybe
Jaeger as well, getting
more distributed tracing in.
From a machine
learning perspective,
we're focusing on machine
learning operations pipelines,
allowing our users
potentially be
able to retrain
on their own data
and getting much more
granular in that aspect.
And then, I think that's
the two key parts.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Thank you so much, Ben,
for spending some time
with me today and sharing
about the video
monitoring systems.
BEN: Thank you, Priyanka.
It's been awesome.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I
don't know about you,
but I learned a lot today--
how IoT devices send data,
how video monitoring is done,
and how all the data is used for
business insights and machine
learning.
My mind is absolutely blown.
But the cool part is it
all begins with a plan,
and there's always a really
cool architecture to uncover.
I've included some
resources for you
to check out in the
description below,
and I'll see you next time.